[Music]
you guys as a couple hi everybody say I
don't take it back alright let's you
know I think you guys are pretty close I
know Casey stick to your guns that's
okay I have to go against him you know
true true I think you guys love each
other
yeah so josh is really not a green here
no I don't know once I love yeah so
there's a new attitude do you guys think
of yourselves as a and I quote gross
couple what's up girl no there were
gross couple I say gross couple I'm
saying like are you the type of couple
to like pick your nose in front of each
other in front of each other
no I'm normal and then it's that guy is
actually a lady and I'm a plumber
you guys are gross sorry I thought like
the PDA clashed she doesn't like she has
a fart in front of me she wouldn't she
poos she doesn't even see she's about to
go poof she just sneaks off I have to go
find her and catch her a Spruance he
waits to have these conversations are
these conversations and then he opens
the bathroom door and he wants to like
talk and I'm like can we just wait a
little bit
no that's cause when you're finally God
I think I'm thinking and I'm like Oh on
the toilet excuse me I'm just picking
your brain it's my time I want to poop
and like I want you if I wanted like
make crazy sighs it is I don't want to
fart in front of them already just cuz I
just don't feel like it's appropriate
you know I mean Altemus now I have no
because you don't want to do to you
either
oh um I guess so like I've had partners
in the past that do that and I didn't
really mind I mean it's still nasty but
I'm like but it's just it's just his
smell is just a lot of things with it
yeah I wouldn't mind Bart's heart if it
didn't smell so bad like you fought all
the time and I'm like
but yeah like I just it's something
intimate for me that I wanted like
control you know make sense I agree
I'll buy you guys yeah I mean Joe to you
know like just in relationships like do
you are you a gross partner no no no
rose partner interesting well there is a
you Casey I would say I am a gross
partner but I out of respect for my
partner I try to not be yes is a clean
part which has a very been so in your
own mind that you forget that there's
people around and you for absolutely
when I have headphones on I'm listening
to music sometimes as far as like Oh
same room that's how it started for me
but yeah so there's a study right now
that has interviewed Britain British
people and Americans you know asking
them like you know on in your
relationship like do you consider
yourself a very gross to mark moderately
gross or slightly gross couple and and
in the way they're measuring is like you
know like do you poop you know do you
clean shows ears like there's some weird
[ __ ] like you you teach others
toothbrushes really do you cheat on each
other because they consider that too but
that's sexual right has to be or in the
shower if I'm on the shower he's people
yes it's in the shower okay your name
murder on partner in the shower partners
hairs popping pimples defecating in
front of partner intentionally farting
not intentionally that's all him not
intentionally not intentionally
defecating yeah I think I think I'd
intentionally yeah it was at the house
we already said though he crapped his
pants all crackers in his dog story
there yeah front address right everyone
was there yeah I was in the den and then
Joe was walking from the kitchen into
like the dining room area and he was
like oh [ __ ] why would you declare it
[Music]
tommy's like you gamble then you lost
[Laughter]
they never across courteous they just
kind of walk away silently and deal with
it on your own again I can't ignore the
noise that everyone who are you talking
to who are you talking about a liar
unlike some people we just find out
Julia Julia I would crap my pants and
blame somebody else Nelson were you
wearing my pants you're focusing on the
wrong part
it's the farting you need to focus on
the the [ __ ] is the silence that you
should be get alright so this study the
so they're asking people like you know
how gross are you and they have like all
these little you know couple things that
people do and see if they'd actually do
it you know and the correlation with all
this though is that they found people
that are more grow couples that are more
gross tend to have better communication
in their relation should I see that a
better friendship better intimacy sex
life and they share more time together
in fact that yeah I guess there's no
privacy right yeah they do share more
time so then just overall they're close
[Music]
I'm agreeing to that because I was super
like I was just raised more reserved
like just you just don't do that type of
[ __ ] like culturally we don't do that
and I've just seen it more in Asian
cultures where it's okay I guess oh so
yeah like him kind of exposing me to
that definitely made like a lot of
communication way easier like there's
there's just don't know there's just
less some like I don't know we're just
closer yeah you also see another point
where like if you guys only present each
other and the most in your best
impression then this I think you're more
inclined to be more attracted to each
other - yes you keep the fantasy alive
and sexually I just see that it just
depends on how they grew up right so if
you grew up with that in your household
and you meet someone that's comfortable
with it the same like there's no tension
there
I think it all depends on how you grew
up and what you're comfortable with but
I also never wanted to [ __ ] anybody in
my household going on like I think for
me sexual sexual things are completely
removed from family for me like like or
from how I was brought up in Aceh cuz my
family was like very conservative about
sex stuff and I went the other way and
so you don't believe in Freud sure I do
I don't know enough to know what you're
talking about
I think will be the basic idea Freud is
that all of our motivations is basically
trying to [ __ ] partners that are like
our parents well family members no
question but but for me my mom like
farting and doing stuff that she didn't
have to have a long-term sexual
relationship with the other that's true
so if Nick you were to start firing in
front of you right you it would start to
desexualize her in your eyes I've just
noticed that in past relationships
sexually the sexual feelings
deteriorated over time because of things
like that for me so so we didn't do that
and we have a better sexual attraction
for each other now that we started
dating you
we do get deeper overtime with each
other as you go through things yeah and
then we don't have we're still dating
each other at the same time which is
[ __ ] sick that's just my theory about
it I agree I actually don't I disagree
with this article - I thought it was
fascinating I you know reading it but I
disagree - I think for me doing what
TIFF once naturally which is to kind of
have boundaries and stuff and not
farting in front of each other and just
having having a proper alone time right
it makes me want her more like kind of
like when you when there's a lack of
time together makes you kind of desire
each other more and I find that to be
more true for me yeah I think for me
though I liked it because I was I didn't
realize how reserved and in a bubble I
was that there were so many things that
were limiting limiting me from being
more open and like real so then as soon
as like I met him and he was that way
you know I mean because I'm just like
wait why did I why did I hold these
things so sacred was it like refreshing
to you oh yeah like even makeup I would
never want to leave the house without
makeup and it was this thing that kept
holding me back like crazy and now it
got to the point where I'm like will you
get in trouble from your parents a lot
if you did induce certain things was
your mom super strict she's like you
gotta have this all you got a proper you
got to do this proper and that proper no
it wasn't like that it wasn't like that
I think just it was just an alien need
to be that way
you were just self-conscious yeah oh so
I just saw a lot of limiting factors
within myself withholding those things
so sacred cuz I'm like why why do I care
about it so much and it took a barbarian
leg bar to break that away and I do live
more freely I will say that I just
forget that humans are around me if that
makes any sense yeah I think I would
prefer not to fart but sometimes things
just come out man oh I think you've
established that well like
everything my thoughts my words my
bodily fluids man if I could I'd piss on
myself and I probably would wait earlier
in life then I should be doing it you
know I hope also that you would declare
that you're pissing yourself oh you know
you have your the pee thing is related
to sexual attraction because then in one
section of this I would say how was it I
wasn't it was funny as [ __ ] if he goes
can I try to God yours like sharing the
shower yeah did you think I was weird
when she asked her you're like well I
think we [ __ ] around a lot and did
goofy things so it was in context it
wasn't out of ordinary wear on your body
did you pee on my leg
yeah don't was your face I would judge
you forever no would you yeah the golden
shower [ __ ] would you ever let someone
pee in your [ __ ] you never seen this
before
well I've seen girls peeing but you
never since y'all are that weird what
now Joe spaces Joe and Susie space
you're the new Joe no it's not even you
Joe
Oh new Joe
now that I seek it out I'm just saying
I've come across I love on nervous
you're getting know you don't like
regretting I said anything god dad no
golden sure thanks okay confident golden
char was when a guy peed on the girl I
think it works both ways golden fountain
that's why okay vessel knowledge no
wonder he's confused yes too many things
was in the lead keys lead car Joe just
pulled up and [ __ ] just walk cross
the finish and then you shot he's
[ __ ] tired yeah it's over I'm not
gonna let you take that one from me
Casey
so wait being in the in the mouth you
would not be done well come in my mouth
if the girl wants it you should give up
bro I [ __ ] do it for I [ __ ] do it
if it makes them horny do I like it nah
thanks for bringing me back let me ask
you something do you enjoy anal girls a
lot of girls will say no but they do it
because they're [ __ ] ride-or-die dude
that's what kind of a giver I am so you
would enjoy anal for your girl never say
Memphis what I'm telling you I haven't
tried it but I'm a committers what I'm
saying what I saw is you actually
visualize it but if she wants to [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]